this is a page taken from the Dragon
Ball Manga and I'm willing to wager that
despite my cropping out of the
backgrounds and filling in each
individual character completely black
you can not only still tell what's
happening but you might also be able to
pick up mine how the characters are
feeling and more than that if you're a
fan of Dragon Ball you know exactly what
scene this is too this is due to clever
character design philosophy in part but
if I told you that there were dozens of
other techniques being implemented
simultaneously before your eyes that you
weren't aware of would you believe me
because what it seems the masses accept
that Dragon Ball's artistic and visual
approach rules if you ask someone why
Dragon Ball's art is so good that's when
you get awkward answers like it looks
cool or the action is sick or damn
Android 16 hella thick and no matter how
true those statements might be they
don't really answer the aforementioned
question why is Dragon Ball's paneling
composition structure the artwork so
appealing to such a wide audience why is
it that when I look at this highly
edited page with no text or context
clues I can still tell what the
characters are feeling and generally
what's happening on the page at a glance
well the answers may surprise you and
give you a whole new appreciation for
Akira Toriyama because while one piece
is second to none when it comes to story
writing when it comes to Shonen visuals
Dragon Ball owns that finish line
I'm toy not Mark and welcome to the
anatomy of manga how Dragon Ball and
Akira Toriyama mastered visual
storytelling
I'm gonna be referencing books for this
video lots and lots of books so if
you're not too familiar with the
fundamentals of comic book design I
recommend checking these out if you're
interested but don't worry I've written
this video so that even my mother can
understand and she thinks Vegeta is a
type of soup so when you open up a manga
you'll see pictures yeah no [__]
Sherlock now mind-blowing Insider side
it's how a mangaka chooses to present
their images that dictates how
successful their stories ultimately
become and so the question is how do
they decide what pictures to draw where
to put them and why well believe it or
not there's a whole long list of
principles and psychological techniques
that have been tested over many decades
passed down from generation to
generation techniques that I a Layman
have carefully broken down into four
beefy sections for your viewing pleasure
so let's kick things off with one of the
easier Concepts
it's a tiny piece flavor okay that's all
it is part one Clarity
Clarity is the name of the game in this
first section and as famed author
illustrator and all-around chick magnet
Scott McLeod puts it storytellers want
two things from their audiences we want
them to understand what we have to tell
them and we want them to care enough to
stick around till we're done to achieve
that first goal you need to learn the
principles of communication with Clarity
communication with Clarity means making
reader comprehension your ultimate goal
due to their sequential and Abstract
nature a manga is massively dependent on
its visuals because of this you might
think that since books don't have a
visual component to their presentation
that a manga has a clear Advantage wrong
because bad visuals can actually make a
great story worse if the page is
confusing the artist risks the reader
making a mistake missing out on a key
piece of information potentially
resulting in them having a lesser
experience or at worst dropping the
comic entirely not good right so while
basic without Clarity taken into
consideration when composing your pages
your Comics visuals might be actively
working against your story rather than
just simply doing nothing however as you
saw at the beginning of this video Akira
Toriyama had no such issues in fact even
if we removed practically every
secondary detail including the narrative
itself we can still on some level
understand what exactly is going on how
did Toriyama the perverted boob drawing
tax evading whiz kid managed to make his
pages so clear well in order to
understand that we have to ditch these
nerdy books for a second and look at the
manga once again and pray to the fair
use God's while doing so for educational
purposes let's use Reddit as an example
one last time this is raditz's first
encounter with Piccolo these two pages
represent the beginning and climax of
their meeting as you can see I've
decided to print off the original
Japanese version of this manga and I've
done so because I want you not to focus
on what's being said but instead to
focus on what's being shown to you but
first I want to try to get across to a
relatively simple concept and to do that
I'm going to use these images what do
you think these are anyone how about now
yeah right much clearer and you can feel
that immediate understanding in
comparison to the first where you had to
stop and think right well that moment of
pause should not happen if the Monger
you're reading has Clarity of form at
the very least in our day-to-day lives
we have the ability to adjust our points
of view to get more information however
not so for our little comic writer
friend here careful and intentional
choices must be made when constructing
your panels on the page so that much
like these two images a potential reader
could understand with just a quick
glance in order for Akira Toriyama to
achieve this desired effect his
characters seldom share page space with
those that look identical to them unless
it's on purpose and that's the joke I
mean if you really think about it all
the different Duos and groups he's
presented in the past Vegeta and Napa
Frieza flanked by Zara and dadoria
Android 19 and 20 Deborah and babade
boss rabbit all of those characters
offer vastly different designs to those
that they stand alongside Toriyama does
this to emphasize his character's
defining features in the case of Piccolo
on this page his silhouette is defined
by his ears and today clothing and even
his hand in some cases each of those
aspects often helped to serve his
character's unique shape but what about
Namek I hear you belching from afire he
looks the same as them first of all
racist secondly don't ever interrupt me
again and thirdly Toriyama made sure
that all of them were either dead
horizontal or somewhere else in the
various scenes that Piccolo was present
in the only Duo that really looks
similar in shape are Android 17 and 18
and they were his rushed fallback plan
when his editor moaned about the awesome
looking 19 and 20 not being enough but
that's enough of my correct opinion
shared for now back to the cartoons on
these Pages the person Piccolo shares
space with Raditz is set apart through
his spiky all-encompassing hair however
purposeful character design isn't the
only way he can visually communicate to
us in fact we're just tipping the
iceberg here and on the topic of tipping
Let's Talk balance but first let me
knock you off balance with rage Shadow
Legends very own creepy guy oh how dare
you do you want to maybe introduce
yourself uh I think you're kind of
scaring the class here Professor death
knight here from Talaria University who
legally not a school with a math problem
if you create a hit mobile game in 2019
how many champions will you have now
over 700 not only does raid have
hundreds of rad Champions it also has 15
amazing factions faction Pop Quiz can
you name the latest faction if you said
The elusive Sylvan Watchers you're right
okay class any questions I mean uh I
maybe didn't say it out loud but I
definitely thought it do not worry that
with all these way Kuro new Champions
you're gonna be like replaced replace me
well if anybody replaces me then I get
to give them advice about everything I
brought to the table you know
that's just more opportunity to teach my
new passion all right name literally one
you're actually friends with then well
I'm friends with literally every
champion
but my favorite new friend is for sure
python you ever been friends with a
lizard man dude makes a killer quiche um
right anyway rain's sick new animated
series called The Avatar is out now and
to celebrate this the team are adding
some of the new characters into the game
as Champions maybe you've already seen
it and no Art Attack this Mighty orc
warlord is making its way to the game
entirely for free just log into raid for
seven days between now and July 24th and
he's yours and hey if you haven't
started playing at all yet use my link
in the description or scan my QR code to
get yourself some awesome bonuses like
this sick Champion Talia it's a whole
bunch of fun and you can find me in game
as toy nutmarch so once again click the
link in our description and I will see
you on the battlefield
have you ever wondered why oftentimes
anime characters look as though they're
struggling with vertigo well tilting one
way or falling over completely at the
behest of a poorly timed gag it seems
that this is a practice that while not
rooted fully in the real world has taken
a hold of this industry as a staple of
its production but there is a reason for
that what is great your reader can
identify the character at a glance now
that alone doesn't tell a story what can
however is emotion and action two things
dragon ball is not in short supply of
thankfully and so I introduced to you
triangles
okay I sent you might be a bit confused
so allow me to explain you see while
ogres are like onions characters are
like triangles this was a principle
first positive as far as I know by
American illustrator Harold Von Schmidt
pictured here dressed like Indiana Jones
64 years before Indiana Jones that's
right this picture's 103 years old he
explains with diagrams drawn on what I
can only assume were cave walls at the
time that typically speaking as humans
we are conditioned to feel a certain way
when looking at these three triangles in
different positions with the first
firmly planted on the ground we feel a
sense of stability with the second
there's a sense of unease created an
unstable and tenuous Line Stands between
its current state and a violent end
through said instability in other words
it creates a bit of anticipation and
tension and finally with the third
triangulum we see something is off
balance and so understand there's a
chance it might fall leading to a sense
of action and danger created this is all
of it abstract and frankly too nerdy
even for me which is saying something so
let's go back and look at the pretty
pictures of the weird alien men throwing
lights at each other if we treat these
characters like the triangles from the
old man's cave drawings we very quickly
begin to understand the principles at
play here and how they serve the visual
story of this confrontation the first
panel is Piccolo's establishing shot
within which we see his normal grumpy
but confident self plotting no doubt to
do more naughty things to Goku and look
he's standing upright in a stable
position just like the triangle good job
Dr Jones continuing down the page we see
this principle holds true throughout the
engagement to reflect the various
characters mental States Piccolo stance
however is compromised and set off
balance immediately after sensing around
its approach suggesting Piccolo can't
handle the big spiky alien man probably
the most interesting application of this
technique in this short section comes
from Piccolo attempting to subvert this
reaction he's had by composing himself
once again through false bravado
standing upright but we all know reading
this that Piccolo's bluffing because of
the way he was standing prior before
bringing the conflict to a roaring
conclusion with a big blast from Piccolo
to Raditz and so if you direct your
attention to the final panel does
raditz's stance shift even slightly off
balance not one bit not a bad
introduction through body language in my
opinion and just because I'm exhausted
from looking at rabbit's stupid face
let's look at other examples of all the
technique discussed thus far on a page I
like to call Goku's first of many long
naps every single character on this page
looks distinct you have Roshi's
character outline differentiated by the
similarly bald Krillin and Piccolo
thanks to the staff he always carries
around with him Piccolo's ears once
again helped to distinguish his
character outline and characters like
Goku Krillin Gohan and indeed Bulma are
all assuming poses that inform the other
and grant us plenty of visual
information Jump Ahead further and
you'll see Goku's initial attempt to
catch bubbles bubbles clearly walting
around as if floating on air is almost
reclined in his upward stance while Goku
heavy footedly Stomps his slanty self
towards the hairy elf ape monster until
he has an idea that is with new
conviction Goku stands as straight up as
he can struggles to get his kid off
until finally we see a lighter version
of him that while still standing off to
one side and slightly precarious on his
tippy toes is clearly more stable than
he once was towards the beginning of
this encounter this is all to say
carefully and intentionally designing
the civil the wets of your characters to
remain distinct from one another is
important selecting the more easily
readable angles to convey their unique
shapes is very important and finally
illustrating their poses in such a
manner that it conveys the emotions of
the characters and the rhythm of the
story at hand which unfortunately is a
principle so seldom spoken about I
consider it a hate crime against books
these fundamentals and basic principles
of illustration serve to increase
overall Clarity which is always a good
thing but also gives each manga a chance
at survival many of you in my audience
would have no reason to know this but
it's worth keeping in mind that the
paper quality these chapters are
initially released with are about as
enduring as Gohan's main character run
in the series that is to say not at all
you'd make better paper trying to duct
tape sawdust together as thin and
brittle as half-play toilet paper that
was left out in the sun to dry this
means in addition to my old weekly
Shonen jumps all looking like they have
book leprosy for an artist particularly
a mangaka in Japan understanding these
fundamentals is not just good practice
it's vital for survival arrival in a
format produced on terrible quality
paper for audiences with very short
attention spans alright so now that we
know the most foundational Concepts
let's start building our understanding
up with different concepts let's start
looking at the exciting stuff
[Music]
part two sequence
now that we're after moving on to the
really big boy material it's time for me
to crush your enthusiasm and interest by
showing you this graph and these visual
aids how awful and crew the teacher I am
only kidding graphs are for nerds
I'm a 31 year old YouTuber talking about
comic book design I have no room to
complain anyway the image I shared just
now that looked like a bunch of scary
ink Swatch monsters is in fact an
assortment of object placement schemes 4
Shots or panels and that's a fancy way
of saying a sheet of potential page
compositions composition as a term is
basically what makes a picture look
right or as a nerd would put it
composition means the distribution and
placement of form shapes colors and
values to produce a unified and
harmonious hole but I would never say
that because I am not a robot or a
Google a common way to describe or
Define manga and comics in shorthand
might look something like this
sequential art coined by comic artist
will Eisner pictured here dressed like
your grandpa after getting lost at
Comic-Con he describes Comics as an art
form that uses images deployed in a
specific order for the purposes of
graphic storytelling or tldr don't those
lovely pictures tell a lovely story and
our friends Scott McLeod's book making
Comics storytelling secrets of comics
manga and graphic novels try saying that
10 times fast he outlines a host of
different practices and rules one might
abide by when sequencing a comic strip
and I'll be discussing two of those
practices right here today choice of
moment and choice of flow otherwise
known as what I want to show and how I
want to show it let's do the moment one
first because it happens in the book
first and it feels weird for me to write
a video about this technique where I
don't follow exactly what the book says
so yeah where was I choice of moment
speaks to the idea that when laying out
your images that tell a specific story
these moments should be like connect the
dot puzzle pieces remove one dot of that
sequence and you end up changing the
shape of the story being told
effectively choice of moment is how one
organizes and chooses to illustrate
their particular sequence each moment
requires a different approach
highlighting or placing focus on a small
Moment In Time requires a different
structure and philosophical approach to
each sequence or specific action what
does this mean and or look like well
let's start from the most subtle and
work our way up from there the first and
most subtle type of sequence is called
moment to moment and while not the most
common approach it's certainly pervasive
in Dragon Ball and my God doesn't know
how to leave an impact typically moment
to moment is used to heighten the drama
with a more cinematic motion to the page
notice the way Goku goads Frieza into
shooting a beam directly at his face
only to just slowly raise his head
afterwards like a badass and that thing
right there that slow and gradual
movement that helps make Goku look like
a badass that's moment-to-moment
paneling these are snapshots in time
captured by the panels to highlight one
or more of the following to heighten the
drama the Cinematic nature of the scene
and to Duncan Frieza because he's a
psychotic slumpy dildo racist as I
mentioned sequencing like this isn't
used everywhere but instead sparingly to
create a specific effect whether that be
for dramatic purposes like with Frieza
just now to emphasize a subtle aspect of
the story like Gohan curling up into a
ball and falling asleep or as Toriyama
loves to do plays great emphasis on a
particular joke moving on to the opening
page of chapter 212 we are given our
first glimpse of what will soon become
one of Goku's most iconic techniques the
Genki Dima or Spirit Bomb as it's
referred to by people who hate it when I
call it the Genki dhama as you can see
on this page we have a collection of
subtle movements because of this you
might be led to believe or assume that
this is our good old friend moment to
moment but you'd be wrong this is a
different Beast entirely this my friends
is called action to action the
composition of Batman to moment to
moments Robin this guy does all the
heavy lifting in most manga's action
sequences instead of focusing on a
specific movement in detail action to
action contends with displaying a single
subject in this case Goku moving through
a series of actions and yes while the
movements are small like the Frieza chin
beam God wasn't that cool altogether
they tell a more complicated story here
with Goku a clear example of action to
action can be seen with this save
Piccolo makes on Gohan with the Cybermen
in chapter 216. from the thwarted
surprise attack to the counter-attack
throw and subsequent final attack result
being the Cyberman is dead and Gohan is
safe once again thanks to to his big
green daddy pickles and in the same way
Piccolo might cut off an attack counter
and eventually destroy his opponent this
sequence introducing the Genki Dharma is
constructed in a very similar fashion
for in the same way if you remove one or
more of those panels from the sequence
with Piccolo making the save on Gohan
you lose information that changes how
the scene or story plays out with this
slow and subtle dance Goku does with his
arms on this page as readers we are all
receiving a vital sequence of actions we
must understand if we are to grasp the
essence of this technique as it exists
within the story and you thought it was
just as simple as drawing cool pictures
how wrong you were with moment-to-moment
transitions like I demonstrated earlier
through the likes of Frieza while they
offer oftentimes special emphasis for
drama a gag or catching small changes
pieces of them can be removed that while
compromising the atmosphere of the page
and the punchline of a joke usually
doesn't result in the destruction or
shape change of the story as a whole I
can remove one of these panels of Goku
looking cool in that scene with Frieza
and while the drama is lessened thanks
to the sense of motion created being
compromised there aren't consequences
for the greater narrative no vital piece
of information is necessarily lost and
just like the piccolo sequence the same
however cannot be said for this Genki
dama sequence each individual panel on
this page is pivotal to our
understanding of this technique's
shortcoming a shortcoming that is
pivotal for readers to understand as the
story progresses against the naughty
spiky boy later on and yet interestingly
for a sequence that's so important say
for a word or two there's virtually no
meaningful dialogue so what exactly is
being communicated then if not verbally
well let's take a look panel 1 is an
establishing shot of Goku Gathering
energy panel 2 Goku realizes he has
enough energy for the bomb panel 3 he
holds it panel 4 focuses it and finally
panel 5 controls it this page quite
literally dedicates each panel to an
individual step in creating a Spirit
Bomb assume this pose to gather energy
register when you have enough hold it
focus it and finally control it remove
any one of these panels and the message
here is lost take away panel 4 and you'd
innocently assume that this technique
can be used as easily as a Kamehameha
remove panel 2 and you justifiably
conclude that this technique doesn't
require concentration or time to charge
the Genki dama is a slow charge attack
that places the wielder in a vulnerable
position and each one of these panels
outlines a specific aspect of the attack
for us to consider without words and now
that we understand that let's talk
choice of flow or flow for short in
other words now that you have a story
that you want to tell in pictures how
should you draw these pictures or panel
them on a page to create an interesting
flow that helps the pictures communicate
the story to the reader and this believe
it or not is the hard part but as I
found out while researching this video
Akira Toriyama had a lot of experience
in this specific area before ever
becoming a mangaka it turns out he
actually began his career as an
illustrator designing ad advertisements
which meant in order to be effective at
his job he needed to be well-versed in
directing a viewer or reader's attention
in a very controlled and intentional
fashion this trick Toriyama is trying to
play her is to guide you from panel to
panel tell you information and not make
it feel like work not make it feel like
reading and that last part it's hard but
he does it and to show you how we need
to take an even closer look at this
Genki Dharma page the first panel is a
downward wide shot with emphasis being
placed on the hands a wide shot is one
that encompasses the whole body but the
emphasis quite clearly here in this
panel is placed on Goku's hands this is
what we are being told to pay attention
to this is what Goku is using to control
this technique using the ink line
surrounding Goku and panel 1 our eyes
are guided to the second in the sequence
unconsciously this is the only panel
Goku's hand or hands are out of the shot
or more specifically pushed out of the
shot this is done intentionally to draw
attention momentarily away from Goku's
hands and onto Goku's face the Keen
Focus that's required to register when
enough energy has been gathered our eyes
are drawn to a sudden spark signaling to
us Goku is ready to proceed and using
the lines in this panel Toriyama once
again guides our eyes downward the hands
are now lowered in panel 3 back into
frame energy emitting from all around
his body Goku's right hand are left is
positioned higher than the other hand in
the panel and again this is a measured
decision like I said with panel one
Toriyama has told us that Goku's hands
are indeed the focus and so this is what
our eye Trail looks like see how when we
go from panel to panel we follow the
hands until suddenly in panel 4 our
attention is thrown downwards just like
Goku's hands to the lower left corner
this along with the medium upshot that
Toriyama chose is working to create this
sense that between panels three and four
Goku threw his hands down in an effort
to concentrate this massive surge of
energy to one fixed point the energy is
no longer emanating from his body but
instead dead his arm and more
specifically his hand and finally
because our eyes are drawn to this hand
this limb of Goku's guides our eyes to
the next and final panel on the page
right onto yep you guessed it Goku's
hand one last time now a closed fist
indicating he has control of the energy
from there our eyes glance over Goku's
expression as he offers a reassuring
smirk before saying okay I'm all set
creating anticipation for what's to come
on the next page all of that all of it
is communicated in just five panels and
look I understand I just spent a couple
of minutes going over this but I want to
reiterate that all of this is
communicated in just five panels
something that would otherwise take me
an afternoon to fully realize and
compose myself came flowing out of
Toriyama like blood from Roshi's nose
haha reference so you thought that all
there was to manga was pretty pictures
and fun writing absolutely not more than
a director in a director's chair
Toriyama needs to be his own producer
cinematographer writer character
designer fight choreographer illustrator
Etc the idea that he not only did this
for every page unconsciously but did so
for over 10 years while releasing a new
chapter every week is honestly
mind-blowing to me in the most humbling
of ways and hilariously to this day he's
still the same toyotaro has even gone on
the record describing how pernickety
Toriyama still is about how a gag is
paneled in Dragon Ball super and I can
see why and while impressive when I
break this down in an academic sense if
Toriyama does it right the readers won't
have time to notice because they will be
caught up in the story everything I
described should be understood or
covered by the eye and quite literally a
few seconds all of that information that
would have otherwise taken pages of
boring dialogue to describe were instead
shown to us in a much more concise
fashion and this is why great panel
sequence and flow is Paramount and so
now that I'm sufficiently tired of
looking at this page let's see how these
techniques are implemented in other
parts of the story like Goku vs Vegeta
is an obvious place to start if not
extremely irritating on for me now this
is a bad example of what I want to
demonstrate here but because the fight
is so blindingly brilliant in its
composition execution and storytelling
that focusing on just the flow of a
couple of the pages alone is kind of
like bringing a tiger to show and tell
in order to talk about why your favorite
color is orange kind of over does in the
same way the prior example with Goku
genkidama placed an emphasis on hands
this places the focus on the positioning
of Goku and Vegeta on the page vying for
top spot if you will both metaphorically
and quite literally notice how on that
famous poser Vegeta is the one
positioned highest on the panel being
the only one not boxed into the page
he's off the charts Goku is a known
quantity but Vegeta is something else
entirely that cannot be contained by the
panels here there's some great flow on
this page too with our eyes naturally
guided back and forth between the two
fighters Vegeta Goku Vegeta Goku Vegeta
Goku Etc it creates this wonderful sense
of timing and tension in the standoff as
we wait for things to kick off
furthermore nice strong stance from
Vegeta 2 and by the end of this first
flurry Goku is the one thrown off
balance with Vegeta never looking more
comfortable standing upright still and
as you might have noticed still atop the
rock formation looking down on Goku that
is until Goku starts to push back and
notice here how Vegeta is once confident
and stable stance is is compromised as
he looks at Goku now taking the shape of
a storm and it pays off with the first
meaningful hit received by Vegeta note
how because of that aura Toriyama gave
Goku he now has a visual toy to play
with that helps guide her eyes from
panel to panel and additionally within
the existing panel to create a sense of
movement finally Vegeta almost brought
to his knees in the process and
terrified to look weak jumps back to a
higher position in order to regain his
footing and look a little bit of
moment-to-moment paneling to emphasize
what this moment means to Vegeta a
snapshot in time emphasized for the
purpose of adding drama to the moment
this one look tells us everything we
need to know he is pissed and just to
put a pin on this section once and for
all if you go back and look at those
scary ink blocked monsters you'll find
that many of them correspond to
toriyama's designs because he's a great
visual Communicator so yeah that was
sequencing time to move on to
[Music]
I gotta stop that
part three rhythm
you see this picture yeah it sucks but
here's the thing when I took it I
thought this view was great but when I
looked at the photo I took I was
massively disappointed now here's that
same picture again only cropped and
suddenly it sucks less why aside from
the Witchcraft that is our Theory this
picture I took didn't look good because
our disgusting human eyes work very
differently to that of a camera lens and
please stay with me on this line of
thought because I promise I'll bring it
back to the laser alien soon the first
image I took is essentially the exact
view I had while standing taking the
picture from my eyes perspective it was
a cool view but the picture didn't
translate because an image taken on a
camera cannot do what our eyes can when
we look towards something or feel the
view is huge but our eyes and brain
isolate our points of interest or Focus
interestingly this exact principle
explains how shutter Shades while making
you look exceptionally stupid also work
without obstructing our vision and so he
says leaning over a comically large
piece of paper containing images of
Japanese cartoons as it happens manga
and broadly speaking Comics tend to
leverage a lot of the same principles
and shots photographers and filmmakers
utilize to prove my point here are a few
that you may or may not be aware of the
establishing shot a shot typically
shared at the beginning of a scene that
clearly shows the area the action is set
it's all over TV shows films anime and
yes even in manga pick virtually any
chapter in Dragon Ball and unless we're
embroiled in something rather specific
Toriyama makes sure to add some sort of
establishing shot next up the close-up
possibly the most fundamental and
foundational concept I'll touch on here
but also by virtue of that the most
important close-ups are exactly what
they say on the tin a shot framing the
subject's face or point of Interest
typically to emphasize a point
conviction or expression key to the
story next is the over-the-shoulder shot
a shot where the camera is positioned to
say it with me now over the shoulder of
one of the subjects in the foreground
typically employed during a conversation
to establish or imply a connection
between the two sharing the scene or in
this case page this is opposed to a
single shot which implies distance deep
focus Toriyama loves using this one he
loves it and to be quite honest it's
easy to see why as a mangaka Toriyama
doesn't have the luxury of being able to
move his camera in time with the actors
on screen and so he employs this
technique regularly by keeping the
foreground middle ground and background
All In Focus to create a sense of depth
and life in his images next is a low
angle shot otherwise known as worm eye
view this shot is used to establish a
sense of domineering Power Authority and
or control for the subject in the frame
and wonderfully whenever you look back
through the series for intimidating
scenes with the likes of cell Frieza or
Vegeta oftentimes they can be found
framed as such and finally just for the
sake of this video high angle shot
otherwise known as a downward shot or
bird's eye view in some sense this
shocks similarly but opposite to the low
angle shot is a presentation technique
that looks down on a character or
subject often isolating them in the
frame sometimes to make them appear weak
small or overwhelmed the there are of
course dozens of different types of
shots some of which apply to Comics but
many others that do not Dolly shots pan
and zooms till shots Steadicam handicam
tracking shots and there are many many
more but you get the point all of those
require a sense of motion to be
experienced by the viewers in order to
be effective however this isn't to
suggest that Comics don't also possess
the ability to do things the TV and film
otherwise can't do and this is where
Rhythm comes in and it's honestly kind
of cool so stick with me here you see in
a movie or each shot of a film it's more
often than not meant to be seen or
understood in its entirety as you look
at it within a given frame everything we
see is taking place simultaneously time
Flows at the same rate as it does for us
at home this is not true for Comics at
least not in the same way things do not
happen simultaneously on a panel let
that sink in thinking about it for a few
moments this should be quite obvious the
very nature of speech bubbles and
conversations occurring within a single
panel suggests a presence or passing of
time that is confined to a a single
panel check out this panel taken from
Goku's interaction with Berger as many
of you are aware or perhaps you're not
manga doesn't read left to right like
Western Comics instead it reads right to
left concerningly because I've now read
so much manga I now open all books that
I start with from the back my idiocy
aside however because manga is read or
interpreted right to left if more than
one character or event occupies the
space of a given panel that means that
the character or event or object on the
rightmost of the panel is seen or acting
first chronologically similarly as we
move our eyes leftwards and encounter
the next object that is seen as acting
second and so on for instance the first
object in this case is barter exclaiming
at the top of his lungs his befuddlement
as to how someone like Goku a Saiyan
could be so fast this signals to us that
wahi noticed and exclaims occurs
chronologically before Goku's response
which wouldn't make any sense if this
panel was to be understood as all
occurring at the same time in other
words burner says something Goku
responds to it and the time that it
takes for that interaction to take place
is the amount of time that this panel
exists within and this isn't limited to
conversations but instead pieces of
information whether they begin you
shocked as he reads Goku's growing
scouter readings or a Super Saiyan Goku
raising his hand to Frieza and Frieza
simply noticing in shock without a word
this is all to say that unlike film
which presents a frame as a passing
instance in time the contents of which
all happen simultaneously Comics or in
this case manga demonstrate panels with
chronological pieces of information that
communicate a certain amount of time
passing in order for the information to
be delivered each panel has a focal
point or a series of focal points that
we move one to the next from for the
sake of Simplicity let's call these
sections or pieces of information beats
as they make up the rhythm of these
stories whether they be actions gestures
expressions or speech bubbles each of
these represent a single beat in the
rhythm of the story being told
interestingly and this brings us back to
the Cinematic shot we touched on earlier
since there are significant difficult
differences in how both comics and films
are depicted this you would think would
result in certain techniques and the
effects found therein not really being
an optioned in the utility belt of a
Savvy mangaka or comic book artist and
again how wrong you are take the panning
shot for example this is a shot where
the camera moves continuously right to
left or left to right depending on the
context of the scene in this clip from
Whiplash it's used to establish a
connection between the tyrannical
Terence Fletcher and his Protege Andrew
it's a technique you would think would
be impossible to use in the realm of
comics but due to the concept of Beats
and rhythm in your panels there are ways
to mimic the effects of this shot
normally found in film with them because
information is segmented across a panel
when the panel itself contains a number
of different beats whether they be
actions or different speech bubbles
specifically if they're from the same
person this helps to establish the
passage of time for instance this panel
with Vegeta pleading with Goku
illustrates a comic's ability to achieve
some of the same effects a panning shot
offers a film notice how the speech
bubbles aren't all crammed together
instead they are separated across the
length of the page each bubble pushing
farther and farther to the left of the
page signifying the passage of time and
pauses between the different chunks of
the conversation furthermore the shape
of this panel helps to get this slow
delivery across too horizontal panels
that stretch across the full width of
the page are seen as lasting the
greatest amount of time heck even
without words it can be effective in
delivering this sense that we are to
linger on this shot just that little bit
longer than the others check this one
out as Vegeta draws his final breath and
delivers his last please suddenly he's
gone with that panel he's presented in
almost insisting upon us spending more
time with than any other panel on the
page there's a pause one that even the
anime reflects the same effect of course
can also be observed with vertically
tall panels usually these are used to
introduce a character or highlight
something about them be it their
appearance or conviction as is the case
in Dragon Ball and again this can be
seen as quite similar to a tilt shot
from film there are of course more
complicated examples but if this
interests you I highly recommend you
check out the books I've pointed to in
this video if you want to learn more and
on that note we finally arrive at the
final stop of this overly descriptive
and honestly pedantic look at the theory
behind comic and manga design and that
final stop is
what the [__] was that Jesus
you're a [__] miserable drunk
part four Focus we've spent a great deal
of time so far examining illustrations
and the panels that contain them and by
we I mean me I've done all the work
you've just kind of been sitting there
bit late so it's now time for some crowd
participation and you will be
participating in this short test or
should I say study and this one is
rather famous so if you've seen this
before sit tight but if it's your first
time I want you to try and count the
number of times the players in White
Pass this basketball
[Music]
uh
how many did you count the answer is 15
but did you notice the gorilla if this
was your first time seeing this visual
trick there's a chance you might have
missed him while focusing your attention
elsewhere but why does this happen
according to will store's book the
science of Storytelling as people or
perception of the world is a limited
hallucination composed of ever-changing
pieces of information information that's
informed by our ability to focus and
understanding why this works not only
helps us structure great stories but
also great surprises and effective
dialogue take this scene from chapter
390 for example Goku and Gohan have made
their exit from the time chamber in the
manga we're not given a tremendous
amount of time in the chamber itself but
all the focus from the team and us as
readers is placed squarely on Goku after
a spirited scene where Goku states he
won't be going back in because he
doesn't need to Vegeta deciding to tease
him about his weakness and then Goku
saying that he's a lot stronger than
even he we get this scene in Corin Tower
where Goku reveals half of his power and
after this bombastic outing nestled in
the lower right corner is a panel
containing Gohan's internal monologue in
it he says that's funny that can't be
dad's full strength with the power of
hindsight being 20 20 we of course know
that this is a clear hint to where the
story is going but watching it for the
very first time following a scene where
Goku verbally Alphas the insecure and
evidently weaker Vegeta all contained in
a story that has up until this point
being all about Goku we of course
interpret Gohan's words here to mean
that Goku is hiding more power than he
otherwise is letting on and I mean
not wrong I mean he's he is hiding power
just not in himself however despite
illustration and composition being the
focus of this video I'd like to chat
briefly about the importance of dialogue
premise and the concept of show don't
tell as it pertains to comics in general
because a lot of people don't fully
understand what show don't tell actually
means in an academic sense one might
think a rule like show don't tell might
be as simple as what it says on the tin
but if that were true then the best
Disney film ever created would be
something like Fantasia considering
there's virtually no dialogue to speak
of it's all show and no tell but this is
obviously wrong because the best Disney
movie is Wally apologies to both
Fantasia fans out there this is all to
say of course that dialogue isn't bad
and expository dialogue isn't bad either
and furthermore no dialogue can still be
terrible panning a camera across a
mantelpiece that covers the lives of two
men as they go from school to boot camp
to fatherhood isn't showing either
that's telling but another form of it
it's replacing what would otherwise be
filmmaking with a home movie and
famously Akira Toriyama wrote his story
with little planning for the future this
is to say that he never planned for the
series to end up where it ultimately did
or take the course It ultimately took he
simply made it up as he went along so
how did he navigate this potential
problem well in the art of dramatic
writing by and I'm going to butcher this
name Legos agree
agree I don't know he says that not
knowing how your story is going to end
is perfectly fine but what is vital to
your story is a premise a brief sentence
that sums up the overall message of your
story things like true progression comes
through struggle or deceit will lead to
downfall are examples of a premise and
what drives premise it's not dialogue
it's your cast or more specifically
character if Goku were to show up and
suddenly start narrating his life story
for the purpose of filling other
characters in or Worse again for the
purposes of filling Us in on information
that would feel exceptionally strange
wouldn't it because that choice of
speech doesn't ring true to Goku as an
established character or most characters
for that matter unless you're talking
about Forrest Gump and his eagerness to
tell his life story is used as a framing
device for the film I mean who am I to
argue with six Academy Awards but the
point is exposition is difficult and
boring to make it feel natural for
instance the conversation trunks has
with Goku when he returns to earth is
natural his motivations are clear and
Goku's willingness to engage with a
harmless strong person all checks out
therefore the conversation takes place
the contents of which happen to be
interesting in that it pushes towards
the premise of the story and sets up the
coming Arc however Toriyama is faced
also with a problem immediately after no
one else heard that conversation in
Canon besides Trunks and Goku and
technically Piccolo so how does Toriyama
solve that problem well he simply skips
over it in one panel citing Piccolo
filled everyone in on the important
information but what happens when you're
backed into a corner what happens when
Toriyama writes Trunks versus Cell in
this you have the debut of a new Super
Saiyan power up but the wielder doesn't
understand why it isn't working against
his adversary so how did Toriyama work
around this problem without trunks
having to verbally diarrhea out his
mouth the explanation to us as readers
well needless to say he didn't do that
instead he cuts away to Goku
simultaneously discovering this
technique informing us telling us in a
way true to his character why this form
doesn't work and this is natural because
he's not only training himself he's
training Gohan and Gohan asks why
however this isn't always the case and
there are of course instances where plot
device characters have to expose it to
Goku in order for him to help out
instances like Snow's backstory that
inspires Goku to fight the Red Ribbon
army or Guru who serves to piece
together the history of that story for
the main cast or even Shin who serves to
recruit the forces of Earth in the fight
against Buu all of these characters tell
a hell of a lot more than the otherwise
show they don't even feel like
characters most of the time if you're
being completely honest so why is it
presented to us this way well because
the story of Dragon Ball isn't about any
of these individuals these are glorified
plot devices used to propel the story
forwards and to reinforce the premise in
the red ribbon Army ARC what's important
with snow is not understanding the fear
and pain that girl felt or the anxiety
she feels about what will become of her
Village what's important is seeing how
the main character Goku reacts when
confronted with this situation she
offers him or in the case of Guru he's
there to provide a path for The
Supporting Cast to enhance their power
through cooperation and for shin he's
there similarly to Sona to present Goku
and the others with yet another big bad
to stop unless you're an enormous fan of
the franchise it's not Beyond reproach
to suggest that these characters are
quite one-dimensional or unexplored and
you know I think that's a good thing a
character that doesn't reinforce the
central premise is as good as set
dressing they don't need exploration
they simply exist to set up the main
character to show what he's made of now
this is of course a difficult balance to
strike when writing your story famously
one piece loves to flesh out a ton of
his characters but you'll notice that
every single character that is fleshed
out in one piece reinforces the premise
of that Arc or greater story in some
shape or form you'll rarely find Oda
writing about something that straight up
doesn't matter to the story for very
long so while keeping all of that in
mind let's take a look back at Goku and
Gohan during the cell Saga as they first
enter the chamber only this time armed
with the hindsight that Gohan is the
main character and how a competent
writer uses Exposition and dialogue to
express information to the audience and
in a fashion that helps to communicate
that very main character shift chapter
377 for all intents and purposes despite
Vegeta and Trunks having gone into the
chamber before them and interestingly
Goku is a supporting character used to
expose it information about the chamber
to Gohan and by proxy us unlike Goku
this is both Gohan and our first time in
the chamber proper Goku explains where
everything is what the challenges are it
even tells us that he wasn't able to
last longer than a month here as a kid
and this is just another thing for Gohan
to surpass this scene places Us in the
same shoes as Gohan on we are learning
here from Goku we aren't experiencing
this for the first time through Goku's
eyes we're experiencing it for the first
time through Gohan's and this is all
telling and not showing in a literal
sense but as Robert McKee writes in his
book story show don't tell isn't about
telling or showing ironically enough but
instead it's about the characters
behaving in a truthful way does it make
sense for Goku to reveal this
information to his son he's about to
train with of course he's his father and
Gohan is obviously confused and so I ask
would it have been better if Toriyama
Drew this information instead of telling
us this information in short no but if
you don't want to take my word for it
pick up any of the books I referenced in
this video and they might explain what
I've asserted in Greater detail oh also
before I sign off I'd like to extend a
special thank you to my friend Manuela
who helped me with this video she's
written a great blog on this very topic
and I've linked her socials in the
description down below she helped with
this video so send her some love next
week I begin my review of Dragon Ball Z
so subscribe if you want to see that but
as for this video it's been long enough
and my legs are tired from standing so
goodbye
that's it for today class your homework
is to download raid just kidding I know
you've already done that so no homework
except there will be a test of Valor so
study up but you can use your phones
because it's a mobile game alright class
dismissed
[Music]
thank you